who do you think is hot Chris Hemsworth
Chris Pratt
Chris Evans Chris Pine just put Chris hi
my name is Stanley and I'm a video
editor do I feel like I'm good at
flirting uh generally no I would I would
I wouldn't say that now but you know
maybe I'll maybe I'll learn something
today hi my name is Tressa and I'm a
barista hi my name is Liz and I'm a
teaching my name is Becky and I'm a
staff attorney I'm super single it's got
a cat but we're just in love not dating
I feel like it's harder to get to know
someone via text because there's so many
like nuances that you don't get to hear
or see I think it is possible to show
your personality enough to get people to
like you or want to get to know you more
via text I've been known to be pretty
quick witted with the text messages
occasionally I don't think I've ever
seduced anyone so many times today
you're gonna see it happen it's gonna be
sexy hello everyone i'm third-wheel
welcome to the group chat this is round
one the speed round
first question describe yourself in
three emojis you kinda have to really
trust your gut okay I'm gonna close my
eyes
Tresa has a girl dancing a hiking boot
and then a palm tree yeah my favorite
out of these three peoples emojis that
describe them I guess I would go Becky I
kind of like this dog ghost rocker chick
combo going on I don't know let's just
do something random let's just pick this
peanut
okay wait is that the guy yeah yeah next
next question what's your ideal first
date in three emojis yo I'm gonna put a
baby
Oh going for broke I just want to do the
weirdest stuff see this is why I can't
be so Tressa picked a baby I'm not gonna
lie tresses I just don't quite
understand movie and then you like
examine the movie over dinner
no no I'm like examining his life over
media to make sure he's on her a creep
yeah okay yeah so I guess her ideal date
would be to go to the movies go to an
escape room and then go home and cook
dinner
that doesn't sound bad ooh next one send
a picture of your shoes I'm kind of a
shoe person so I'm kind of curious liz
has some like checkered flip-flops not a
huge fan Tresa showed her actual feet oh
yeah Becky's got all birds I heard those
are cool Becky didn't show her feet
either I don't know if they were told to
do that because they don't want to
reveal who they are or they're just
ashamed of their feet last question cats
are dog I am allergic to cats
liz is into dog O's Becky is a puppers
person cool I hate to say it but I think
tres is kind of on my bottom she says
cats a thing that might be the deal
breaker there I was such a dog person
for so long and now I'm a dog I just
adopted a cat and man they're fun oh I
can't decide both
so I'd eliminate one Liz Tressa or Becky
[Music]
it's a little harder than I thought it
would be I just keep thinking that like
your guys's responses I would have no
idea who you are either he's not gonna
know I don't know I feel bad cuz like I
feel like I don't know these people at
all I'm just basing them off these
random shoe pictures
I think I'm eliminating Tressa her like
ideal first date answer is kind of weird
depends uh I eliminated the love of my
life and I'm not gonna play myself oh
there she is
oh sorry Tressa no I'll never know if
she's loving my life just goes Liz and
then we'll see how it goes
Hailey and Liz welcome to round two
what's been the hardest part about
dating oh that's cute you guys put the
same thing he just copied my answer he's
a follower oh well I don't know if that
makes this really good for each other
really bad for each other road bumps are
you hitting I'm not a people person
wow that's not a the best answer this is
third wheel jumping in cake or pie ice
cream Wow look at her she's not even
she's breaking the rules here I'm
partial sea salt and caramel ribbons ill
whoa she said you
oh wow she just saw my favorite ice
cream flavor I was gonna kind of say the
same thing about hers but I didn't want
to just straight-up give the you what's
your ideal vacation so I loved Tokyo I
hated London cuz the food suck oh my god
I love London the food is great in
London time is up this didn't go very
well she said she's not a people person
she on my favorite ice cream flavor and
then
I hate it on London it's food and then
she said that she loved it that doesn't
bode well Stanley and Becky welcome to
round two
I'll get us started with a question what
are you looking forward to partner in
one sentence Becky said I'm looking for
a partner in the true sense of the term
preferably someone funny I feel like my
answer was terrible it could have been
better
your answer was basically what I'd say
to you she said yeah cuz it was a good
answer it's got a little bit of an
attitude okay this is third wheel
jumping in if you could have dinner with
anyone in the world who would it be
Queen Elizabeth I love her is that the
one that's still alive Anthony Bourdain
is dead
and the knot has to weigh not know what
happened to Anthony Bourdain no one
specified okay this is third wheel again
fancy dinner or a food truck I prefer
fancy dinner first dates probably a
little much though okay times up that's
ain't around to sale you don't have five
minutes to choose your next elimination
in the winter who you'll meet IRL please
standby I felt like the conversation who
lives wasn't that great she's like I
don't like people which is like not a
great thing to hear we bumped head on
London and our ice cream flavors but
also I don't know like is that enough to
like never want to know this person ever
again I don't know I mean he just seemed
like kind of like repeated answers back
like I know but I also feel like he like
I don't know I don't want to date myself
let me go over this Becky thing I felt
like there that didn't go as smoothly
either she hated on the fact that I
chose a dead person even though no one
said that I couldn't someone who can
dish out some I guess maybe I I'm
leaning towards Becky I mean I'm always
a little apprehensive about people who
bring up diminishing returns when it
comes to her state agreed also he didn't
seem that impressed with Queen Elizabeth
which is a big red flag because she's
amazing and a badass family time is up
please text here who is your next
elimination
live sorry oh wow
okay whoa I mean she's a looker I uh
[Music]
it's fine no whoa whoa how's it going
good how are you you're Becky
I am Becky how was it
you know I felt bad eliminating people
off of very like kind of arbitrary
things it was unexpected not how I
expected my Friday afternoon to go but
it was fun do you want just go and get a
cup of coffee
yeah let's go all right sure let's do it
[Music]